the ph at the equivalence point of the
titration is measured to be 2.54
which of the following indicators would
be the best choice for determining the
end point of the titration justify your
answer well let's just remind ourselves
the end point of the titration is when
the indicator changes color and because
we that's our signal our visual signals
are saying hey we must have hit the
equivalence point you want the pka of
your integrator to be as close as
possible to the ph at the equivalence
point if the ph at the equivalence point
is 2.54 well which of these indicators
have the closest pka to that well we see
thymol blue has it at 2 right over here
so we would choose to use thymol blue
thymol blue
because
it's
pka
closest
to
ph
at equivalence point equivalence
equivalence
point
there you go